Ці чоловіки насправді фермери тепер Вони
служать у танковому підрозділі одному з
найбільш різних на полі бою воюють на
радянському танку т-80 40-тонна машина
яка пересувається зі швидкістю до 80
кілометрів на годину лякає ворога Каже
навідник Василь Ну я вам скажу такого не
тільки бачуть і єслі танко виїжджають
через дрони тоді вся арта Все працює
тільки на нас Вони забувають за піхоту
за все значить бояться але старі
радянські танки потребують постійного
техобслуговування ось цей наприклад на
років 10 старший за механіка Ігоря і це
видно якщо великий труднощі перешкоди
там оце ось бінокль він часто була
лопається потребує заміну
так же Ось проводиться періодично
натяжка гусениці ці танки можуть бути
старими та зношеними але їх легко
ремонтувати щоправда за умови що
чоловіки зможуть дістати запчастини
часто їх знаходять прямо на полі бою так
багато запчастин підходять до наших
машин
дуже часто
трофейні машини розбираються на
запчастини
такий ходова частина підходить і
частково до мотора запчастини підходять
на початку повномасштабної війни
українці зіткнулися з переважаючими
танковими силами ворога але росіяни
часто припускалися тактичних помилок
залишаючи танки без прикриття тож
українцям вдалося вивести з ладу аби
захопити близько двох тисяч танків але
щоб повернути окупованій території
українському війську самому потрібна
істотна модернізація тому військові
чекають прибуття сучасних танків від
країн-партнерів вони по-перше
маневреніші у них зовсім
друга
обладнання стоїть чому нас так само
тепловізори дальноміри це все інше
Да і система хороша
екіпажних зачищеніші в них Капсула
стоїть ззаду і з боєприпасом що при
пострілі в капсулами пропасу добре А в
нас же ж ні в нас сидимо
на
українські танкісти буквально сидять на
боєкомплекті танка тому в разі прямого
попадання ворожого снаряду ризикують
життям нові західні танки розглядають як
запоруку успішну українського контрнату
союзники пообіцяли Україні сотні танків
як сучасних таким модернізованих
радянських станом натепер в Україну вже
прибули перші танки Леопард 2 А6 і
Челленджер два зокрема Німеччина
передала 18 леопардів два норвегія-8
португалія-3 а Польща - 14 Франція
поставила першу партію легких колісних
Танків а mx10 RC 14 із 40 обіцяних а
Польща Чехія і Марокко передали партії
модернізованих радянських т-72 так само
леопарди два в різні модифікації Україна
ще має отримати від Іспанії Швеції
Фінляндії та Канади а Влада Німеччини
схвалила передання Україні 178 танків
леопард 1 А5 у США пообіцяли передати 3
американський танк Abrams такі західні
танки набагато сучасніші та ефективніші
за старі радянські на полі бою по-перше
це краще безпека екіпажу танка Адже всі
снаряди перебувають в окремих боксах і в
разі займання вибухова хвиля спрямована
в іншому напрямку по-друге мають кращу
броню потужніші двигуни більшу вогневу
міць і дальність гарматного пострілу
ми справді маємо згадати часи холодної
війни НАТО та захід більшою мірою
орієнтувалися на якість російська чи
тоді ще Радянська сторона на кількість
від українських Танкістів ми чули що
тітанки які вони отримують звичайно
набагато сучасніші ніж танки часів
холодної війни і це суттєвий Крок уперед
у порівнянні з танками російського
противника наприклад їхній броньований
захист вони набагато жвавіші на полі бою
не менш важлива і наявність так званих
систем управління вогнем такі танки
можуть вести бій також і ще один чи не
найважливіший фактор це те що вони
зможуть розпочинати бій з російськими
танками тобто стріляти по російських
танках і знищувати їх ще до того як
російський танки опиняться в
безпосередній близькості І вони зможуть
робити це із дуже високою швидкістю за
словами західних аналітиків через
санкції Росія не здатна виготовляти нині
сучасної військову техніку а сучасних
танків на озброєнні у них мало тому РФ
здебільшого використовує старі радянські
танки У той час як українські військові
вже проходять чи прийшли навчання на
сучасних західних танках
якщо ви зазирнете всередину російського
танка то зсередини вони досить
примітивні за винятком найсучасніших
яких у росіян дуже мало Коли ви залазите
всередину західного танка ви оточені
електронікою бронею та сталлю іншими
словами що обкерувати таким танком як
леопард-2 Челленджер або особливо Абрамс
потрібно значно більше тому те на чому
захід зосередився Я думаю Останні кілька
місяців і зосереджуватиметься до кінця
року це підготовка членів екіпажу але не
менш важливим я наголошую Не менш
важливим її забезпечення логістики
постачання та ремонту бойових машин Вони
отримують також не такий Скажімо так
гламурні але безумовно робочі бойові
машини піхоти Та бронетранспортери вони
також потрібні бо не можна воювати лише
танками вам потрібна піхота Це помилка
яку росіяни зробили на початку війни
Утім щоб розпочати ефективний
Контрнаступ українським військовим
потрібно повністю укомплектувати
сучасними танками нові батальйони тобто
дочекатися всіх обіцяних поставок а не
частинами впевнені західні військові
аналітики а доповнити їх мають бойові
машини піхоти і велика кількість
снарядів як ми бачимо і як ми чуємо це
не та цифра яку хотіли отримати І хотіли
мати українці Тому нам потрібно почекати
гадаю кілька тижнів щоб побачити
остаточну кількість яка прибуде в
Україну але що насправді важливо Це те
що ці танки мають кращу якість і
українці добре Навчання на цьому новому
обладнанні Я б сказав тож це матиме
значення на полі бою
ти
європейці потрібно набагато більше
європейські постачальники леопардів і
особливо Німеччина обіцяли поки що
близько двох батальйонів танків це трохи
більше 100 танків британці дуже маленьку
але дуже ефективну роту це 14 танків але
українці не отримують цих 100 танків
Незважаючи на всі фанфари Можливо вони
не отримують 100 аж до осені а вони
просили 300 танків набагато ефективніше
якщо використовувати їх масово і так як
хочуть використовувати українці у
їхньому контрнаступі як масовані
штурмові сили у великій кількості є
експонентний ефект з різних причин немає
сенсу мати їх у малих кількостях Тому їм
потрібно набагато більше і вони
продовжуватимуть просити набагато більше
і вони мають рацію
кількома десятками сучасних танків можна
створити лише локальну перевагу над
російськими військами цього вистачить на
один-два невеликих
наступили
починаючи з травня українці мали
перевагу на своєму боці вони задають
темп війни як ми бачили було три великі
виведення російських військ з території
які вони раніше утримували На даний
момент є три фронти це Крим Бахмут та
Запорізький Якщо коротко То в Криму
українці досягли невеликих успіхів за
останні кілька тижнів у бахмуті росіяни
досягли невеликих успіхів цінує жахливих
втрат А на півдні Запоріжжі поки великий
знак питання тому що це найбільш
очевидне місце для українського наступу
в 2023 році тому обидві сторони
зміцнюються там І вичікують що зробить
інше
українцям потрібна більша кількість
техніки Якщо це станеться ЗСУ зможуть
почати Контрнаступ на Сході та півдні
країни